the big news today is that vladimir
putin has challenged joe biden to a
debate a
live debate after biden called
him a killer biden spoke out about the
russian president in an abc news
interview this week abc news reports
quote i've just thought of this now
putin told a russian state television
reporter
i want to propose to president biden to
continue our discussion
but on the condition that we do it
basically live as it's called
without any delays and directly in an
open direct discussion
it seems to me that would be interesting
for the people of russia
and for the people of the united states
they say putin's invitation
seems to amount to a challenge to biden
to a live televised debate following a
day of diplomatic uproar
that began when biden said he thought
putin was a killer
in an interview with abc news's george
stephanopoulos russia recalled its
ambassador to the u.s
in response to the remark now uh i think
vladimir putin's a killer
well i think vladimir putin thinks
vladimir putin's
i know do you think he was like oh man
he called me a killer can you believe
that he called that he called the
ambassador home to high-five him
i mean the guy was a kgb colonel yeah
all right he's
you know he's not he's not mr rogers he
was like watching tv and then when biden
said it's like that leonardo dicaprio
meanwhile like points to the tv and then
like
you know his body his kgb buddies are
like yeah
they're like dude the president just
shouted you out and he's like oh yeah
and then now now he wants the debate
because he wants biden to say it more
oh i know you called me killer thank you
not even that it's like biden calling
him a killer
is good for vladimir putin it makes him
look strong
it makes him look you know dangerous you
know i
look i i i was old school cold war i was
literally in the cold war
in the army and i i i learned a lot
about how to fight russians and
everything i kind of
kind of don't like the russians do like
the ukrainians spend a lot of time there
yeah ukraine's cool but
ukraine is cool yeah um but uh
this russia is not the threat it used to
be
it is a threat it is not a pure
competitor it's got a lot
it it it's like a [ __ ] with a strong
right arm
do you remember when uh obama called
them a regional power
you know he he they're not quite a
regional power but they're not quite
the superpower that they were because
they can't project force the way they
did they do have nuclear weapons
but look if you want a real threat it's
china and if you don't want to talk
about china you talk about anything
else yeah including russia or extremists
yeah so we've have you ever heard of
china uncensored i have not heard of
china
big youtube channel they talk about
china and things that are going on there
and they mentioned that you know when
biden was transitioning
some of the people were fairly pro-china
speaking about how it was
good that jobs were going there there
was a certain like diplomatic
incident i suppose where these guys were
deferential to china
and there's fears that as you know china
has taken hong kong already
yes they're they're imprisoning the
uyghur muslims they want taiwan
and they will take taiwan and joe biden
will not do anything to stop him
uh joe biden's gonna have a decision
point when they move on taiwan first of
all they wore game it they know how to
do it and i'm not talking about anything
outside of uh open source stuff you read
this stuff anywhere
there are war games uh recently revealed
where
for years americans have been you know
we practice war games
and we lose against china and
china's got a lot of advantages when you
look at taiwan taiwan is very close
taiwan's very far from us we have to put
ourselves on a few bases
which are easy to hit easy to target
small concentrated areas we also have
very few ships compared to what we used
to we used to have what a
what a 600 ship navy with ronald reagan
i believe
we're now under 300. wow really yes
are there a lot of uh submarines that we
don't know about uh there is nothing
people don't know about uh you can't
like secretly build a submarine
because it's like 10 billion dollars and
they know where our submarine bases are
where we manufacture submarines so you
take satellite pictures
what if they have like a subterranean
manufacturing plant
um moving all the materials and i would
notice it
i think i think it it's kind of hard to
hide a ship
it's you can hide submarines can hide
out at sea
obviously but they have to come in and
they have to restock and refit
right right uh so i i mean i think we we
know the numbers the problem is the
numbers are growing for the chinese the
chinese are serious military
you don't find them uh doing a 60-day
stand down for the extremist boogie men
who don't exist look i spent 27 years in
the military okay
i didn't meet any white supremacists i
didn't meet any extremists i met people
who wanted to do their job
and well then what you're basically
telling our audience is one of two
things
either you didn't look hard enough or
you're lying to protect them because
that's the only
the only joke joe biden says okay we got
to weed out these extremists
okay so so what's going on huh which one
is it well yeah
man checkmate good point
um no it's a it's a lot easier to talk
about you know
mythical extremists they're claiming the
gadsden flag
was a sign of extremism like some guy
had on his facebook profile the gadsden
flag so he got removed from dc
you know guard duty or whatever it's the
symbol of the american revolution
like don't some states have that as
their state flag or something maybe
maybe the american revolution is uh
going to be branded extremists
i wouldn't be surprised they're already
there you got the 1619 project
claiming that the real founding of this
country was 1619.
oh so actually they've already said the
american revolution was racist
they've said that it was a bunch of
racist white landowners trying to
preserve their slaveocracy it's really
weird
how the beneficiaries of
all this alleged supremacy stuff are
also the
very same people promoting it yeah
it's weird because it's all affluent uh
uh establishment types
and of course the establishment has
changed it's no longer like you know the
guy who has
buick dealership in town yeah instead
it's the
professor gender studies did you uh did
you hear about the elephant walk that we
did in guam
this past year um i i know we did one
and you know we were treated right oh
really we were treated because
i guess trump or somebody ordered that
we were gonna do a show of force
long story short my understanding china
sent a strike force
through this you know the strait of
taiwan or whatever and this was
a show of force the u.s responded with
what's called an elephant walk
where we get bombers and fighters and
they start going around the runways in
guam
and then they were treated because the
u.s was advised
china could blow up that base with snap
of a finger and our plans would be able
to get off the ground
uh it is a problem that the chinese have
decided to pursue an asymmetrical
offensive they look they find our
weaknesses
the thing is we have a limited number of
bases okay on
land so you just target everything there
we have a problem they've got all of
china and they have mobile missiles
yeah so if they you know where's the
missile i don't know it's on chinese
highway one going up and down the coast
i mean i think this is this is why joe
joe biden calling out putin has been
nothing but good for putin
i think the whole russian narrative has
been nothing but good for narrat for
for for russia it projects you know
america saying russia is the greatest
threat
and then they can use that as to puff
themselves up make them seem bigger than
they really are it's kind of a sugar
high i mean because i mean they kind of
know
you know that you know most you know
half our population is going to die
at 57 of vodka poisoning because they
make it in the radiator of a zill
truck and do they really do that or are
you just being
being a jerk i i'm being a jerk but but
you know you never know man i mean they
dude if you spend your time over there i
know i spent time in ukraine not russia
i've seen i've seen them those dudes
right yeah man you don't want to drink
the stuff that hands you in oh no i was
going to say they figure stuff out they
do
and they're smart yeah when you've got
limited resources because of communism
oh yeah they figure out how to make
vodka a radiator oh my gosh the the
thing is we're going to see that more
here
tonight the thing is working overseas
and i worked overseas in kosovo among
primarily among the albanians and these
guys they they were just no law
they were they were smuggling and
scamming because
they had had to for a thousand years
other people had conquered them
and oppressed them so there was no law
and order
right these are not guys who stop at the
stop sign at 3 a.m in the morning when
they're out driving
americans will because we're used to law
and order we're used to well
if i if somebody breaches a contract
i'll go to court and my contract will
get enforced
if somebody hits me with a hat a bat a
cop will arrest them
we can't take that to grant for granted
so we act as if
there's law russians never did that
because there wasn't it was all
arbitrary
yeah the albanians didn't in kosovo
until we started putting things into
place there
and i think that's one of the things
we're losing here
as people lose the ability to appeal
to institutions to protect them whether
it's department of justice
uh you know the news media remember the
news media should be out there saying
hey
look at these towns ruined because you
know jobs are getting shipped off to
china
but they won't do that because that
makes democrats look bad
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you